في ظل التغيرات المجتمعيه التي نشهدها
اعداد الاشخاص غير القادرين على ارتباط
بالشريك حياه والدخول في علاقه عاطفيه
يزداد يوما بعد يوم فالعثور على الزوج
المثالي لم يعد يكفي بحسب دراسه حديثه من
جامعه ريولا بولايه ماريلاند الامريكيه بل
من الضروري امتلاك مهارات الحفاظ على
العلاقات الرومانسيه الدراسه اشارت الى ان
مراحل الزواج اصبحت مختلفه تماما في عصرنا
الحالي فالافراد الان يفتقرون مهارات
كثيره تؤدي لنجاح لارتباط العاطفي وتكوين
الاسر منها مهارات المغازله والذكاء
العاطفي والنقاش والاستراتيجيه لحل
الخلافات واداره المشكلات مما يجعل كثيرون
يفضلون العزوبيه طواعيه وليس اجبارا
[موسيقى]
لماذا يواجه كثيرون دكتور اليوم بحسب
الدراسه صعوبه في ايجاد شريك حياه بخصوص
صعوبه وجود او الالتقاء بشريك حياه هو
مشلق قله عدد الذكور ولا شح في عدد الاناث
ولكن خلينا نقول لغياب النوايا الحقيقيه
من وراء هذا الزواج او هذا الارتباط
فكل من يدخل هذه التجربه يجرب حظه خلينا
نقول يعني هو ما عنده ابعاد
والاركان الاساسيه اللي ممكن تقوم عليها
نجاح هذه التجربه فبالتالي كل من يعتمد
على الطرف الاخر في انجاح هذه العلاقه
يعني ما في ما في هذه المسؤوليه والجديه
في ادنى الانسان يطور من نفسه ويغير
مفاهيمها او يطورها ويشوف مثل خط فصال او
ميزان يتوازن في الاثنين في فهم بعض من
خلال القيم من خلال الاولويات قائمه
الاولويات في العلاقات كذلك طيب دكتوره
هيا بصراحه اي مشكله ومن عند مين هل
الرجال اليوم لا يلبون طموحات المراه ام
المراه اليوم ليست على قدر تطلعات الرجل
على من المسؤوليه
والله انا اشوف المسؤوليه تلقى على كاهل
الاثنين لانها هي علاقه قائمه على شخصين
يعني ما نقدر نعتمد على طرف واحد في
انجاحها لازم قلت لك مثل ما قلت لك لازم
يكون في الكفين متساويين يعني كل واحد يجب
ان يقوم بدوره طيب الدراسه تقول دكتوره
انه الطرفان اليوم
يفتقدان مهارات الحفاظ على علاقه طويله
الامد منها مهاره ذكاء الذكاء العاطفي
النقاش والتفاوض حل الخلافات بين الطرفين
واداره المشكلات ما رايك بذلك ماذا تنصحين
من يبحث عن شريك صحيح صحيح انا اشوف في
قله في قله الوعي كذلك مهارات التواصل
الاجتماعي وكذلك مهارات الذكاء العاطفي
مثل ما قلت لك حتى احنا عندنا في الثقافه
بشكل عام في الوطن العربي يمكن نشوف ان
الاعتماد يلقب بشكل اكبر على المراه بحيث
انها تكون يعني هي محور البيت او هي محور
ان تدير هذه العلاقه بشكل اكبر ولكن هذا
يسبب ضغط اكبر ولكن الان اختلفت يعني
موازين الحياه اختلفت يعني حتى المراه
نشوفها بالطلعه اكثر حق الحياه عندها مثلا
اهتمامات اخرى غير العائله فبالتالي هي
يعني مسؤوليه يعني يعني تتطلب جهد من
الاسمين
[موسيقى]